hey guys it's the evident caitlyn
podcast the podcast trending number one
by imaginary friends in some world in
some multiverse this is number one and
that's the multiverse of imaginary
friends so you have logic fun i'm not
sure we're gonna get a little real don't
real is fun real is fun you know you
don't start a podcast they're saying
it's guys not gonna be a fun pod can
leave there's gonna be a very
interesting podcast it's a podcast we've
it I kind of always intended to do but I
thought it'd be later I wanted to get
like more just like fun fluffy ones in
or like substantial ones because I guess
in my head I worried that it might sound
like it's complaining but I also wanted
to give a peek behind the curtain of
like what is real behind the content we
put out and there's nothing that bad
almost all the time but right now I have
a hernia and I am dealing with that and
it it might affect our our work going
forward and I thought that this I don't
seem like something nice friendly yeah I
could bring you guys behind the curtain
on this because it may affect our
schedule it may affect other things I'm
not sure yeah you probably have to get
some sort of surgery some surgery yeah
so it's it seemed like it might just be
weird if we just like went dark or
something but one thing that's great
about the shift we've been making
towards you know this podcast and doing
casual videos and doing some twitch
streaming is even if we can't do the big
projects like building a shed or like
renovating a room we can still stay
engaged with you in the more casual way
yeah like even if you're recovering from
surgery even if I'm recovering
yeah yeah and I think that that's
something that's been on our mind for a
while since we first started the channel
you know we based it around DIY and
often sometimes like our best-performing
content was big things yeah it usually
is the big time-consuming like
physically larger pieces yeah our rooms
and and that's something that we enjoy
but we also have more in our life that
we want to share and I think we talked
about this in past episodes since we put
all of our time into making content and
what we're doing with our time needs to
work with the content we're trying to
put out I guess one of the worries we
had is that in the future we may not be
able to always make that content at the
same pace that were we were setting the
pace for if that content is like a big
furniture build or room renovation every
week yeah yeah like let's say that maybe
one day we want to have kids who knows
that that affect our content the content
we were putting out let's say one of us
get sick let's say one of us needs to go
into surgery you know we wanted to like
start moving towards content that's a
little bit more flexible and like a soft
way so that if we ever needed to go
towards that content it wouldn't be like
a hard switch yeah I wouldn't be like
like sharp left turn yeah yeah and so
that's that's just happening sooner than
I expected
yeah it's well it's crazy to like we've
we haven't been good about resting yeah
very much um so like we've done a few
videos with you not feeling great and
it's hard cuz there's like some times of
day where you feel good enough to work
at some times of day where it's really
terrible yeah and like we we keep trying
to squeeze out videos you know cuz I
mean we want to do videos we like doing
videos we have these ideas that like we
want to get out but at the same time you
know I think logically in our heads we
know we need to rest but it's
kind of hard it is hard well also you
know we've been keeping up such a nice
pace of productiveness and we both like
being productive and making content and
like I don't know it's just a satisfying
thing for us and it's it's hard to stop
and still keep that satisfaction you
know what's interesting is like you're
saying one of the reasons we kind of
started making this shift is because it
seems more sustainable long-term and
it's not just cuz it's like oh it's
easier to you know make a video about
like some small vise jaws or your cat
liking tape than it is to do a laundry
room vent renovation part of it is like
we have a little bit more flexibility
and just being goofy when it is a
smaller project and we have more fun
with that yeah
but ironically like part of that shift
was also introducing things like the
podcast like streaming on Twitch like
the enk Tuesday videos so we've
essentially gone from like a video a
week to a video week plus an occasional
second video plus a podcast a week plus
streaming several laser okay so like
we're doing more stuff but it feels like
more it just feels like we're going
towards the path that we want to be on
so it doesn't feel like more work
necessarily even though it is like more
items to do yeah but it is it is
definitely a shift that we've been
underway and I think I think I've set
out we already talked about this a
little bit but you know I hope that like
probably most of the like you guys who
are listening to the podcast don't mind
the shift I'm hoping and like hopefully
you guys understand why we're kind of
moving in that direction more now I'm
not sure if my wares are making sense oh
there's another thing about the hernia
it is painful but the worst part about
it is I just like haven't been sleeping
for the past 16 days
yeah so I'm words are definitely hard
right now yeah yeah but you know it's
it's it's still satisfying to be able to
put out content ooh this this leads me
back to like a theory that I've had for
a long time the thing theory
everyone needs a thing yes you know I
think that people need to have like
their thing like their their sense of
identity when you introduce yourself to
someone like what's your thing you know
or if like if your parents were
introducing you to someone what's your
thing so when you're growing up you're a
student you're an athlete you're a
student athlete you're student athletes
whatever whatever you know
musician I don't know it's like everyone
has their thing and I think that that's
a really important part of like being
happy and satisfied with life a little
bit and I think that one of our things
now is creating content and I think that
if like something happened to us where
we couldn't create content then that'd
be really upsetting to us and I like
that we can create lots of different
types of content in lots of different
ways so there's just increasing our
flexibility to continue making content
in the future yeah I mean in like I kind
of mentioned earlier it's not just
because we're forcing like oh some of
the content we've been making would be
more difficult to do it's it's not just
like avoiding potential trouble is like
we're actively doing this because it's
what we want to do yeah you know and the
ability to avoid potential troubles and
still be able to make content to me is
like a nice added bonus but I think the
main thing cuz that you know if there
are troubles or more difficult times or
whatever that's temporary yeah
times but all the time outside of that
is still time where you're like putting
all your efforts towards making content
and being able to do stuff that we're
really excited about is the most
important I think and so that's like the
main reason for the shift but this is
like I think the situation kind of I
mean we've always in the back of our
heads thought like you know if we do
have kids one day or if one of us does
get sick or injured or whatever these
types of videos will be
year but now we're kind of in the middle
of that actually happening yeah so kind
of brings it to the forefront and you
know we're not like the podcast isn't
like established yet our twitch streams
aren't like established yet you know
like right right now it doesn't really
make sense monetarily or business-wise
to be putting our time into it when we
could be making more videos like content
we can make that we enjoy making that
like we interact with you guys and it's
yeah I think that this might also be a
good podcast to mix with the like you
know real life first YouTube like what
you see on YouTube double juicy like
super really toasty is it our lights I
think it might be our line commuters and
the computers and the servers use [ __ ]
your sweater on the light okay you need
to change no I'm good I look great arm
pops okay so I think that that this is
an interesting topic to us because when
we watch other people's YouTube videos
we always analyze it and like to kind of
figure out what's going on behind the
scenes and how they do things and why
they do things we analyze the crap out
of it is it's really fun we like watch
YouTube videos and go on walks and
discuss them like like our streets or
our meeting office yeah yeah the
neighborhood Street neighborhood streets
yeah so I think that one thing we can do
is we can shed a little bit of light on
how our real
life is different from our YouTube
videos yeah and it's it's actually not
that different but I think that it's
kind of interesting because to make the
content that we make like especially our
older content that would take place over
three to five days you know we take all
of that footage maybe like 30 hours or
something when we have to compress it
maybe not 30 hours it's maybe not 30
hours it might be like 10 hours 10 hours
okay like 10 hours of footage that was
probably like the worst case scenario
right take 10 hours of footage and
compress it to 10 to 20 minutes and
that's that's that's a tough chore to
condense that as much as we do and what
we end up doing because I think that it
makes the best content is we grab all
the highlights all of the funny moments
and stitch them together and tell a
story with them with you know dialogue
putting them together but I think that
like the things that get cut out from
the video are just a moments like where
we're just working and it's still
enjoyable but I don't know I think it's
kind of boring content it'd be boring
content it wouldn't make for the best
content and then a lot of what's also
not missing in like what we put out is
everything that goes into the content
that we make all of deadening all the
social media all of the website
maintenance emails the sponsors emails
about merch emails about like supporting
the products that we've put out there
like just everything else that goes into
our business that's something that
doesn't really get captured either and I
think it's just kind of interesting
because I've noticed that there's a
perception out there by some people of
like oh you're just having fun and
that's true but there's also a lot of
work that goes into it and I think that
this is originally the episode that I
was thinking in my head that I wanted to
do some time and I wanted to hold off
because it sounds like complaining but I
just wanted to like bring you guys
behind the curtain
with us a little bit how many curtains
just all of the curtains does all of the
curtains I wonder if I can like put some
curtains behind us because I can't find
any like real nice graphics I'm just
gonna like get two still JPEGs and just
like move them out like it's more like
sliding doors and curtain them but I
don't know I don't I think it's kind of
interesting an interesting topic yeah um
I think like one comment will get every
now and then and we generally we don't
get too many oh you're bumping
everything okay yeah okay you good I'm
good okay if everything shook for a
minute in the video um one thing that
like we don't get to too many negative
comments really like you know you
weren't settled I asked if you were
settled
we don't get too many negative comments
but one I guess kind of negative one
that we get sometimes is like oh
nobody's that happy all the time and
it's like well yeah this is like over
the past few days the highlights of our
video where we are like joking around
and stuff and that's not to say we're
like not happy the other day I like you
that sometimes like well shoot a scene
and then there's like a bunch of sanding
required and it's like okay well we'll
either both just put on our headphones
and knock this out real quick or Evan
I'll do some sanding and I'll go work on
editing the can we just filmed yeah you
know we're not yelling yelling and
happiness which is like we are happy
people but you know we aren't happy all
the time I think that like we have about
like like your happiness level
okay I actually have a list of like
what's what's that what's that list I
have it's really corny name yeah I
thought I was like your life cheat sheet
my life cheat sheet
yeah I've been series go oh very down so
I think that that kind of everyone has
like you know everyone at any new point
we can put them on a scale of like 0 to
10 of how happy they are you know and I
think that certain people have like a
baseline of happiness like let's say
that someone's baseline is 5 in most
days they're around 5 and when something
good happens they peak up to 7 and then
they go back down to 5 and there's no
bad happens they drop down to 3 and then
they go back up to 5 but like most
people and I think that like I was kind
of inspired by this thought by a TED
talk it's not my original idea at all
but I think that most people
overestimate how much happier happy
thing is gonna make them and
overestimate how much bad things will
make them sad and most people generally
have a baseline I think that we
generally have a higher baseline of
happiness in a way and not to say that
happiness is like the goal either you
know I mean happiness is a nice thing
but like happiness isn't this is another
TED talk I'm just like ripping off TED
talks here but happiness that'd be a
good intro already done but I think that
what was I saying
oh yeah happiness is such a hard
nebulous goal to aim for you know like
okay my goal in life is to be happy yeah
now where's my checklist it's really
hard thing to do it's really hard thing
to do it's real hard
I'm just leaving words out right now but
I think that good question things like
being productive or finding satisfaction
your your job or you know like there's a
lot of concrete goals you can go after
that might improve your life and that
might lead to happiness but yeah I'm
just going all over the place and the 5
guys aren't I got like to reel in like a
scatterbrained way I'll just call it a
spelling
having Kaitlyn get real podcast and then
play would you rather oh yeah we didn't
even do like the overview or tried and I
was like so today we're gonna have a fun
podcast and you're like we did a lot of
googling but it's it's it's it's yeah we
don't need to get into like what a
hernia knowledge ease on hernias I don't
know yeah yeah maybe maybe maybe a
surgery podcast maybe there's a few
archived plans there's a few archived
ones okay what were we doing
Oh happiness baseline and happiness
baseline overestimate the effects of
happy things or sad things because
really they just end up going back to
the baseline I know where I was going
with this okay looking at our old videos
that took you know it's not like they're
old versus new it's just in the past we
mainly did a certain type of video and
now we're mixing of more variety in but
there's been a gradual shift in our
earlier videos you know we would take a
longer period of time and crunch it in
really snug but I think that in a way
our more recent videos that we've made
where we are like recording it all in
like one session and it's like with the
tape episode that was just like it
wasn't real time because we probably
convinced two hours down into 15 minutes
yeah but that's a lot better than
condensing like four days and 15 minutes
yeah I think that honestly the content
that takes a shorter a shorter period to
make is actually the more real content
yep you know we can leave yeah we can
leave like like III can like in the tape
episode I'm just gonna bring that up as
the example for this we haven't seen it
this is our supervisor or I guess we
titled it like our
cat ranks her favorite tapes Tuesday
well there's a lot of scenes than that
where we just used silence as the humor
or like you know just like waiting for
her to do something or to sniff the tape
or hey but you know we were able to
include more moments like that which are
which is kind of more real I don't know
yeah because we weren't trying to we
didn't have to be so brutal to cut
everything down to fit it into a video
time period yeah it's like when you're
when you have so much footage there's so
much good stuff and I think that we've
even released on patreon a few times
where I like our video with Bob we went
to Bob and we got video with Bob from I
like to make stuff I can use words when
I try we ended up with a lot of good
footage I think we release like we
trimmed out as much as we could in like
one brutal pass and we ended up with
like 40 minutes or an hour yeah of like
well we thought was pretty good stuff
and then we took that 40 minutes and cut
it down to 25 minutes which was hard and
then we still got like comments like
like Bob built a whole table you built
in that in his video short or you made a
funny faces good content I think that
like you know maybe we're too
sentimental towards the content that we
make I don't know I think it's just like
focuses because when you were doing
step-by-step stuff we we planned out
everything we were gonna say and we
there we were very conscious about like
there will be basically no moments where
we're saying what we're gonna do and
we're not overlaying footage of us doing
oh yeah yeah super efficient and we're
super efficient super conscious of
everyone's time watching the video cuz
it's like hey if you're watching this
video to learn how to do this thing we
don't want to just sit for five minutes
telling you
do it and then do it for another five
minutes like I wouldn't be five minutes
but you know what I mean like yeah we
would overlay footage and we still do we
do like a mix of that now but we do a
lot more in the moment us talking to the
camera saying what we're gonna do and
then we show how to do it and sometimes
all overlay it a little bit but like
when you're like the gold video is more
to like fit all the steps in in an
efficient way and show like how to get
from point A to B to C etc that's a
different focus than like when the focus
is like capturing funny moments and just
kind of like yeah like making the
audience feel like they're hanging out
with you yeah that's a different goal so
I think like there's different criteria
that you filter what you've recorded
through that determined what makes it to
the final cut or not and sometimes that
means it's a thirty minute video like
that doesn't happen with our collab
videos like our our video with Johnny
Johnny Brook after workshop was another
super long video our Alex deal we got
like a few videos with Alec and they're
all super long our one with Bob was
super long there's this a lot of good
stuff yeah there's a lot of good stuff
um and that tends to happen more because
like I'm recording literally everything
yeah more good stuff gets copied more
good stuff gets captured and it's like I
can't it's good and it's a lot harder to
edit oh it's so much I've gotten better
like it some of our more recent collabs
I've gotten a little bit more efficient
and like more confident and being able
to like Bill and Brett and stuff yeah I
was like a little bit more efficient
with those well I go going back to our
goal and Bill and Britt when we were
hanging out with Bill and Britt from
punish props bill like and talked a
little bit about his like mission
statement and their mission statement
and what they kind of want their content
to do and to be and I think since then
I've been thinking about that some
without success like without coming to a
good conclusion but I think that one
thing that and not that we have a
mission statement I also want to say
this but like how I kind of see us
fitting in
the grand scheme of like like making and
making on YouTube and all of that is
like I wouldn't mind for us to be at
like the top of the like the content
funnel of like making we're like we
hopefully catch a lot of different
people get them excited about making get
them aware of what's possible and get
them like like excited about it exactly
and then if they want to go down the
rabbit hole of woodworking or 3d
printing or any of the other things I
think they can go down those rabbit
holes because they exist you know but I
think I you know we're not there but I
think that if I had a goal if I had to
choose a goal right now that's what it'd
be yeah and I don't really think that's
like the same as a mission statement but
it's more like where our channel stands
in relation to other maker channels what
type of audience we hit and I think we
would like to have kind of like maybe a
more wide net and I mean it's partly
because like we like to do a lot of and
we've realized that we have more fun
with the videos if we're not going into
every single detail about every single
step so that does by its own nature make
us more like an introductory yeah even
if we're doing advanced stuff we're
still like an introduction to those more
advanced things cuz we're not going into
detail every single little yeah you know
and we have gone far from where we
started I know I keep thinking like
what's the title this podcast gonna be
is it let's get real and then like in
parentheses distracted real and
distracted I don't know it's a work in
progress you'll notice we basically had
all these ideas listed for like podcast
ideas we can do in the future
Evan just took like four of them but
yeah I feel like we could we get I could
keep going on this but I don't know how
deep that roads gonna go or what podcast
topics are gonna use some tactics
let's let's just let's just roll with it
and I think
see where it goes and you know what I
think that naturally in the future we
might roll back into them that's true
that's true because also I mean gosh
think about how much has changed since
we first started making content our
perspective our everything you know a
time like our process and all of that so
I think that my guess is that we're
gonna keep on changing yes we keep
talking about it remember back in
episode zero zero four but I mean making
it they've been doing this for four
years something like that and they're
you know in their podcast they say like
we're still figuring out we still don't
know what we're doing it's still
changing we're still shifting and I
think that that's kind of a good thing
in a way I think III wouldn't want to
get to like a static point where we just
aren't changing I don't know and I'm
like thinking about it yes whatever I
can refine my theories I can I can bring
up more points from my life cheat sheet
yeah or TED Talks
more secrets listening to TED talks and
I'll just pull out my life cheat sheet
and to start taking notes but it's like
the TED talks have resonated with me the
most and we're like you know it's kind
of like gathering all in all the
information rewording it in my own words
so that makes sense to me because like
guys these these people to give these
TED talks are really smart really smart
and you know at times when you're
looking at like I get like a simple list
it's hard to get those smart ideas
across quickly so I dumb it down for
myself which I think it's kind of hard
and impressive I'm very impressed I
would use logic for five points I think
that's I think that I think we covered
everything that we wanted to yeah thank
you guys I think one thing that I
definitely
thank you guys for joining us along this
journey as we figure things out as we
explore new things and supporting us as
we go through the ups and downs of life
yeah which are inevitable and like it's
different from a normal job where your
life and your work are very separate
yeah you know this it's all the same
yeah I know I know a hernia is
unfortunate but like it could have been
a lot worse I mean I definitely don't
want to complain too much there's people
going through a lot worse and I'm fine
I'm gonna be fine I mean like our friend
Simone is going through something a lot
more difficult yeah you know brain tumor
stuff yeah brain tumor stuff man that's
that's that's scary stuff so we're
thankful for the health that we have and
I don't know where was going with that
one again and now it's play game to
celebrate celebrate okay so we went back
and forth on a few different games but
we settled on would you rather because
we're prepared for it okay so want me to
go first now I'm gonna go first I have a
great one okay you sold this one either
better be great yeah okay would you
rather eat a handful of hamster poop
nuggets or not brush your teeth for six
months Oh eat a handful of hamster poop
nuggets I mean nah brush your teeth for
six months like like that's like a
moment of pain verse like six months of
pain and maybe a lifetime what if you
get cavities for one month now still
what if it was
what's your threshold a week I don't
know I don't know I might go week
without brushing my teeth
to avoid enhancer yeah and I would just
like not eat anything with sugar maybe
there's like oh you know you could
probably eat the system like get like
eat fibrous like eat celery at the end
of the day like you know to really like
scrub your mouth yeah yeah I'm sure that
there's like so you can't brush your
teeth but what if there's like natural
remedies that people used in the past
that what if it was like what what if it
was like okay you have to really really
stretching this one question in the
whole topic
to eat a ham a handful of hamster poop
nuggets once a day for a week or not
brush your teeth for a month not buy
from a week in the month yeah all right
now I'd flip a coin I'd eat the hamster
poop nuggets I imagine it's just kind of
like seeds ground up see you can you
like prepare them can you like like like
like like you know like like like dry
them like what's that thing called
dehumidifier that like you dehydrate
them crush them like add in some like
[Laughter]
that's really creative I think okay cool
so would you rather fly but be really
slow or be able to run as fast as a car
like fly like fly but you like at though
at a normal person's walking pace fly
but at a normal person is walking pace
me too just cause like yeah I could run
as fast as a car but I could also just
like get in a car if I needed to yeah
you're right like a bonus yeah it's not
really like a bonus but flying even if
it's slow think of how likely I would
yeah you can just like but also it's
like so useful it's like you're
exploring the Grand Canyon he's like
he's like fly walk across it or
something like the most relaxing way to
fly I think like even if I could fly
fast I might fly at a walking pace maybe
that's the benefit okay okay that was a
pretty easy answer maybe maybe I should
have gone faster what if you can run as
fast as a jet then that's then that's
utility then that's really useful you
know we could go visit your parents like
and run there would be like both like if
only one of us got the power of these
superhuman so run as fast as a jet I
might run as fast as a jack for like 40
minutes or 30 minutes to get you know
running there's a lot of running
shameful where would you run would you
be like in traffic with cars cuz you
might be little you're kind of limited
by the car okay fire maybe still yeah
yeah yeah if I could like transport
automatically or if I had some magical
transport fast
yeah if I had a personal or I mean yeah
yeah if I had like a personal self
flying jet that I could hop into that
could fly at the speed of a jet yeah you
know but then then then you're getting
both for one you know cuz then you can
fly in a plane is a lot or a jet it's a
lot different than like me being able to
fly yeah that's that's true you like you
being able to fly is like it's a pretty
cool idea I thought yeah I do I thought
I still might pick fly alright your
question okay I don't remember we wrote
these down a long time ago yeah like
these are kind of fresh to me too
okay would you rather would you rather
be in a coma for five years
and then when you come out of it you get
five million dollars or get your leg cut
off and you get five million dollars
right away leg cut off five million
dollars right away mmm
just cuz like that's a lot of life five
years imagine like five years ago I know
but at the same time think about oh yeah
having a leg that's forever but then you
can get a bionic one with your five
million dollars then you're even yeah
but you could also like if you're in a
coma for five years that does suck but
them together no it's just is this one
person just one person pest
that'd be sad I'll do the leg cut off
this goes like we'll get like a really
cool bionic leg yeah really cool bionic
leg or something if million dollars
isn't like it sounds weird saying this
but like that's not like live the rest
of your life okay well the money doesn't
matter cuz it's the same for both make
it five billion dollars five billion
oh then leg for sure and you just get
really cool Bionic or just like you can
even like III don't know I feel like
money compensates more for a leg than
for time I don't know time is the most
valuable things chair you know but I
guess like the thought is if you have to
go through you're gonna have to go
through some sort of even if you get a
bionic leg it's not like you pop it on
and all of a sudden you're good you're
gonna have to go through a long time of
physical therapy and relearning to do
things and you're still gonna be
hindered and things you can do like
can't go swimming with that thing you
know you can totally go swimming with
with just one leg you can't go in like
ocean waves that are like rough where
you have to like really paddle and stuff
like you could just go get like a like I
can swim just fine using one leg okay
maybe like there's things that you can't
yeah that you would be limited in your
ability to do you know that's for life
five years yeah that's tough maybe was a
year I might choose the year was a year
I think I would choose the year yeah cuz
the year goes by really fast five years
that's hard I don't really know the
answer there is no right answer I guess
I don't know but I think that I was
listening to the modern maker podcast
and Chris was saying when he worked at
his day job he wanted time to go faster
often like when he was at work he wanted
it to go faster when it was the weekday
he wanted to be the weekend he always
wanted time to go faster and now that
were an invoice for the case for him and
it's the case for us now that we're
working on our own things and it's like
really meaningful and stuff we always
want time to go slower we always want
more time and just like the thought of
losing that much time like what we could
do what we could accomplish what we
could learn what we could how we could
grow and everything it's just that time
is yeah a lot yeah okay I didn't expect
us to like riff on these ideas so much
okay what's yours okay would you rather
be able to teleport anywhere mm-hmm or
read minds teleport anywhere really yeah
really I feel like yeah most people are
I just gonna born God like okay so the
reason you would want to read minds I
mean it could be like Oh what do people
want to see on our channel we'll do that
and be really successful or or we could
like like gamble and win a whole bunch
of money or like the gaming the system
or gaming the system or it could be like
super successful business people or you
know we could read people's minds yeah
it's like you can read people's minds
but that doesn't necessarily I guess if
you're gambling and you're like playing
poker and you can figure out what
everybody got yeah but like I feel like
you only get to do that a couple times
and then like they realize you're
cheating you know what I mean I don't
know they they they realize if someone's
like winning too much that they're
cheating if you're gambling but like I
feel like like reading minds would be
beneficial but it also might just it
might like literally like get in your
head yeah to where it's hard to think
about like well what is it that I want
yeah anymore
you know because like if you're just
thinking about what other people want
and trying to do what other people want
or play that system like that could get
really exhausting and also just because
you can read someone's mind like let's
say let's say we're talking to a sponsor
doesn't you know very like small
so we're talking to a sponsor yeah and
we're like oh I wonder what number they
have in mind then we can read their
minds and figure it out and be like huh
well that still sucks
I know but yeah not what I was hoping
for so it's not always like a good one
cuz like like the best case are reading
minds did you get the truth from people
but like you can also get the truth from
people by like establishing trust and
being good at communication and using
words and no it's like and sometimes the
truth might not be good cuz like going
back to like the content stuff like the
first time we released a kind of silly
video it was everybody was like oh man
that was really bad you know and like
we're keeping on you know like being
silly in our videos but if like we got
to hear all the people who were really
like man they're kind of like grading on
me it's yeah maybe it would be
beneficial for our channel and some in
the short term because we could change
and make those people happy but in the
long term because we're doing what we
want to do eventually like yeah and
that's okay yeah you know so it's like
in some ways I might get in your head
too much and if you teleport then like
and then like instead of staying at a
hotel you just wore back to your house
yeah
yeah she won't be stays you do like we
can do like spills and an exotic
location
yeah we can like do a build on like a
mountaintop majestically come back right
we get to travel at times I actually
don't don't know if I would variables
but like would we be able be able to
travel with oh yeah yeah I'd know like
teleport they're naked that's like would
you take the option of being able to
teleport but you can only teleport naked
yes I'd like yeah pour it into like a
dressing room put on some clothes and be
like I will buy these clothes well oh
you won't have any information with you
you never steal it I'd set up like safe
houses around the world
[Laughter]
you could you could mail yourself a
package of clothes and a wallet to a
hotel pay for the hotel yeah and then
tell and have it delivered to a room
it's like the hotel would be like so
like weirded out by that impromptu
addition would you rather yeah you'd ask
the the read minds versus teleport oh
man I've only done two I have seven
total Wow yeah okay
would you rather own a cat that had
human hands would you rather have cat
paws for feet have a cat that has human
hands that's a strange question I don't
know I'd want to have a cat feet can you
explain this logic a cat with human
hands okay these questions are really
sparked interesting debate were you like
really riff on them cat hair
[Laughter]
[Music]
would you rather be able to control fire
or water right
okay okay yeah it's like I sink in water
right cuz like if you can control fire
you could like do an impromptu campfire
you could cook things you could you
could do all sorts of things like that
fire is like fire is like adding heat
into the world water is like controlling
water but I don't think of a water it's
like you can't make it colder or warmer
you can just like so I couldn't like
freeze water
no you couldn't freeze that'd be a power
of our ice but I just askin if I also
have power over ice and water vapor and
you said yes you can move ice you can
move it and you can't turn water into
ice cuz that'd be the power over like
but you know what some people okay so in
some theories of magic people who can
control fire can like move can like
remove heat from water so it's like
you're controlling heat but what you can
do with heat is you can like take let's
say you have some hot water you can suck
all over the heat out of the water
turning into ice and you create a fire
over the ice so let's add that in so so
this getting complicated
oh it's a water if I control fire I
control ice also you can't control ice
but you can like you can remove all heat
from an object okay and create ice
create ice so in some ways it's like oh
you could maybe reverse global warming
like can you suck it out like power of
like let's say okay let's add some logic
to this like because there's there's
some theories of magic where it like you
just have energy and you output it as
heat or something
but I think that a more interesting
theory of magic I'm sorry I'm really
Mary
it's like use chance for heat so you
have the power over heat basically that
means like if the room is like one
temperature and you want to heat
yourself you can suck the warmth out of
the room heating yourself but the whole
room gets cold so if I wanted to like
prevent global warming could I suck out
some of the heat and then just like
shoots that heat into space yeah that
might be a good one but then like you
create like a localized cold zone in
order for like it to work you decide to
be like flying constantly and shooting a
continual fireball out into space North
Pole and just do their you do it we're
like the glaciers are melting yeah and
it just really plays back okay that's a
pretty noble goal yeah yeah I mean I
feel like that is the one that would
because like a bug if you have the power
over water you could like walk on water
you could like jump into the water and
have it like move you around you could
like make a boat out of water and like
like jet around in your water boat I
mean no one does sound more fun
maybe there's fun stuff I can do with
heat too oh really I don't really like
being too hot well you can always keep
yourself at the exact really guilty if I
chose the water one just because it
sounded more fun if the heat one could
fix global warming mm-hmm I don't know
if it's worth it living with that guilt
if one of them can fix global warming
you kind of have to choose that one yeah
even if it would be cool to like walk on
water yeah I mean that's a noble noble
choice I can still walk on water you can
freeze it freeze it step by step all the
way down to the ground say how like how
powerful I was you can't stand on like
in like over the rihanna's trench like a
little stream dam and all the water
would flow around and stuff I can again
like every time I take a step it it when
I remove my foot it goes away and melts
back I see you're trying to stretch
things okay that's that's a good choice
though I think I would have chosen fire
too even though water does sound fun
what would it what were your reasons for
fire was it like similar or what like
fires more utility water is more like
but like but like let's say during an
apocalypse
oh no fire would still be really really
useful yeah a thing like you could like
purify water you know control over heat
that's worth like I mean you could you
could create energy with either because
you could like manipulate the water -
yeah like a waterwheel a waterwheel I
was like not a windmill good job you
have a chance to redeem yourself after
[Laughter]
listening go get it okay like thinking
[ __ ] hear it they could hear the wind
in the fire okay hmm would you rather
have a conversation with your past self
or your future self future self duh I
don't know
I think past self I would tell my past
self hey go do this oh so you but that
but then your future self would
disappear like like bug okay so time
travel with you are you guys so so okay
so if you go back in time and talk to
your your younger self you're creating
an alternate timeline for the self that
you talk to and then you travel back to
your time nothing little changed because
that was a different timeline that you
went back and altered you created a new
timeline so that perversion of you
they're gonna live a great life but you
don't get a benefit from it so I'd
rather have like a conversation with a
future me then I get a benefit right
away at this moment you know yeah think
about it I don't know there's no way for
you there's no way for you to go back in
time talk your old self and come back
second time and benefit it and be the
same person because you're gonna
inherently be a different person you
know cause like like the timeline that
you are in mm-hmm you know you're you're
creating a new timeline that's yeah
that's true that's true
time like like time travels really funky
guys yeah no no I know that's an easy
answer for me because like going back
time and telling a past version of
yourself information then they they get
a benefit but you don't but if a future
version of you came visited you then you
get a benefit from it cuz like what
would you want you'd want money success
to live your life a little differently
etc etc you can do the same I mean you
know we ended up at a really nice place
what if you go back in time and tell
your old self about me
and then we never meet somehow what
would you tell so so if you're choosing
I'm talking to your future self what
would you tell slash ask future self oh
you know probably just like okay so a
few things mmm
one ensure our financial success so we
didn't have to worry about money yeah
I'll ensure like kind of like our
long-term happiness like you know like
what what what what job should we do
where should we move which we live you
know like not avoid natural disasters
and health concerns and unlike any other
like bad things I might happen to us so
basically just to make our life better
yeah pretty my only ones after this
ourselves how about how about we just do
one more each okay this is something
that like we're gonna have potentially
very different answers on would you
rather communicate with animals
excluding humans using your mind or
communicate with computers using your
mind
excluding humans also yeah your computer
isn't a human no oh sorry I thought you
were saying like would you rather be
able to talk to animals but you can't
talk to humans oh no no no no like
addition like in addition to the
communication you have right now so it's
like like telepathically communicate
with animals
or telepathically communicate with
computers man rockin it jube right now
and I want to know what's happening yeah
but wouldn't it be great to just look at
your phone pull up whatever app you want
how about this be typed out send it
shoot out emails like crazy and it like
a wizard I think I would have to choose
computers because like it's so useful
like talking to animals would be super
fun but it also like after a while you
might just realize like oh like like a
cat only has his few size not too much
else and I kind of already guessed what
those thoughts were okay what about this
what if you can grant one animal but not
change their lifespan grant one animal
human intelligence and then and then
also be able to talk with them oh it
still shoots computers yeah computers I
mean that's if you can't change their
lifespan but you give them human
intelligence it's like Hello tiny human
trapped in a cat you only have a
lifespan of like that's so sad this many
years that's so sad yeah so I went to
like a deep dark place without cats
could live to 20 yeah they can live a
long time yeah okay
doobies gonna live forever forever
okay um would you rather only be able to
eat your three favorite foods for the
rest of your life so think of your three
favorite fruits doesn't really matter
what they are but you could only eat
those for the rest of your life so how
specific is it like cheesy pasta or
pasta I think it needs to be more like a
meal if you don't sit down with that
okay like a category of foods but like a
specific one okay so would you rather
only be able to eat those three favorite
foods from the rest of your life or
never eat those three favorite foods
again for sure okay sure we're always
finding new dishes new meals new for new
favorites it's like we have like three
that are like ooh hmm
you know hmm tasty tasty coming soon
evident Kaelin kitchen but no no no cuz
like man we we we can barely eat same
thing in a row just like two days in a
row yeah we're always trying you know we
cycle through our favorite dishes yeah
yeah it would be hard baby so no all
right it'll be hard yeah and also is
that just for dinner is that for like
you only get three meals unless you had
to eat for breakfast lunch and dinner
[Laughter]
maybe one last one okay okay one last
one all right would you rather have your
stinging sound perfect how are you am i
stinging have your singing have your
singing is down perfect for you uh-huh
but to everyone else it sounds mediocre
or would you rather have your singing
sound mediocre to you but perfect to
everyone else perfect to everyone else
but then like you're always gonna be
doubting you're always gonna be like
doubting whether or not people are
actually like enjoying it and you're
gonna step on YouTube you like people
are watching it I guess it's okay well
like you know like buy your own singing
you can sting perfectly to yourself and
you'll always be like hearing this
beautiful voice now I don't have to feel
weird you're saying my singing isn't
perfect beautiful thank you yeah that's
why I don't sing too much in these
YouTube videos or anything that goes
online because I'm just afraid of being
sued I'm afraid of getting that
copyright infringement because like cuz
you're like so on key so I can show you
that no no I see I can do that
in like a half a second that's really
fun yeah we have a few more questions
that we didn't get to so I foresee is
coming back to them
woody rather is one of my favorites it
was a really good one
yeah I mean I did like the debate last
time song guessing games
so you listed three what's the one that
we haven't listed the one I didn't come
to mind though well it came to mind but
it wasn't as my favorite okay all right
we gotta go okay there's a but do we get
it all right call it call-to-actions
oh we need to say thank you to everyone
who's given us iTunes reviews that just
makes us so happy to review to read it's
okay it's one of the slow dumb ones like
we can get him okay thank you for giving
us iTunes reviews it's it's kind of
surreal to see those pop up oh and we
anyway it's it's like fluctuates but
number nine yeah we got to number nine
and then like I'm sure we've gone back
down and up and down and up again but on
the charts for United States gaming and
how you do your thing of the week while
I get this but it's it's super awesome
and we really appreciate you guys
listening and and giving it reviews and
sharing and all that stuff and while
Evan gets this bug I'm going to do my
thing in the week bug Cup okay
so that's a secret yeah okay so my thing
of the week is and actually David
brought this up on making it but it's
coming up in the news again because
there's Netflix yeah because there's a
Netflix show but the Marie Kondo like
true magic of creating tithing out of
you yeah yeah no and I have a Netflix
show but we read the book a few years
ago and at least one
a year we kind of do a huge overhaul in
our house and just get rid of a bunch of
things that's crazy how much like the
volume of stuff we've gotten rid of like
like run away or given away or sold it's
it's mind-boggling like we could
probably fill up half of this room with
the stuff we've given away just like -
yeah no I probably felt this whole room
with like all of the stuff we've gotten
rid of oh yeah since we like really got
serious about the process yeah since we
first started it yeah it's one of those
things where like the first time we did
it was pretty easy and it it gets
progressively harder half of the
low-lying fruit in a way like the things
where you couldn't make an easy decision
about but around stuff like we have we
since we started the business we've been
gaining stuff a lot more quickly you
know part of it is like tools and things
for the workshop sometimes because we
buy it sometimes the spot because the
sponsor is like here use this thing and
so like we just accumulate stuff faster
materials for projects things like oh
this robot kiss like now we need a robot
kiss until the robot I think some of the
hardest things though we're like the the
things that required action like do you
want to throw away this computer that
may or may not work do you want to get
rid of these CDs have you backed them up
like what like like like you had to make
hard decisions at some point where like
if I look at a t-shirt and I haven't
worn this and I'm not gonna wear this
that's easy but if you look at an
engineering textbook that is part of
your thing part of your identity and
that you were using to study for like
your professional engineering degree
that's part of like your identity and
giving it away is much harder than just
getting rid of a t-shirt you know so
there's like there it reaches a certain
point where it gets really hard here
that's like really quickly like there's
there's no way we can do justice to the
book and like a few sentences but I'm
gonna try to summarize it in the past
when we tried to get rid of stuff we
looked for the things that we wanted to
get rid of in a way and with Marie Kondo
she encourages you to gather everything
of a category gather all of your
t-shirts
and pick out the ones that you love that
give you joy and get rid of the rest and
that's like an entirely different way of
looking at it but it makes the decision
a lot easier yeah it makes you be a lot
more harsher on in your decision-making
harsher is not the right word but yeah
like you get rid of more than you would
if you were only looking for like well I
know I hate this shirt it's like the
threshold of like where the decision
gets made on terms and they're like love
versus hate scale is different when you
look at it at like well I keep
everything I love and I get rid of stuff
I don't like there's a lot of gray area
and they know like clothing is like she
kind of goes per category and it's
different for each category in a way and
clothing is this the easiest example to
give up because like there's a lot of
like gray area clothes you don't hate
them now this is kind of going back to
what I was saying earlier is since we
started the business it's a lot harder
now because we're making decisions
personal things for a business it's like
we might have some camera equipment that
we got when we first started but we
don't need it anymore because we have a
better version but it was like kind of
expensive thing at the time but it's not
really like that great in comparison the
stuff now you know and so it's hard to
make decisions about those kind of
things but also it's like I think that
as we continually purge stuff we get mm
more confident about making the decision
more confident but also we get
experience we like like think of new
ways to think about decisions that lets
us reframe things so that we can get rid
of things easier yeah so like one thing
that I often do and I started this like
with clothes and stuff but I think you
can apply it to like pretty much any
category of things but you know if I
have if I have ten I'm just going to use
clothes in 10 t-shirts but like I will
always wear if I have 30 t-shirts but
I'll always wear these 10 and these 10
are my favorites and when I run out of
these 10 I would rather do laundry than
wear any of the other ones then it's a
sign that like even though those other
20 are fine totally good shirts you
don't need them because you're always
going to choose the work of doing the
laundry too
that end over just wearing shirt number
11 whatever I think it's the same with
like camera equipment if it's like oh we
have a I don't know like if we if let's
let's say we have three cameras mm-hmm
and we always go for one and if we need
a second we go for the second camera and
we never use the third we should get rid
of the third yeah but it's more than
just that it's more than like but it in
situations where you need the third we
grab our phones instead yeah because we
just don't like the third or we just buy
another case you can go you can work
through that future of logic in your
head and say okay we're never gonna use
this ever again
yeah it's like maybe you're holding onto
some wood or some really an entire
episode on this you know I don't know
holding on to like some some you know
stash of wood or whatever that's like
totally good it just hasn't been right
for any of the projects you've done in
the past two years and you always buy
new stuff instead yeah maybe it's time
to give that wood to somebody else you
know yeah that's not something we've
been slowly realizing yeah we still need
to go through our garage a lot alright
moving on to my thing my thing of the
week is a specific game a game that
we've been playing on Twitch it's human
fall flat it's so good and I think that
like with with like kind of the hell
things that's been going on with me I
just love it because it makes me laugh
it makes me have fun and it makes me
forget that I heard it's really fun and
distracting yeah it's it's like just to
give a little insight into the game it's
like super floppy mechanics so it's kind
of frustrating but I'm too clumsy drunk
people that are jealous all puzzles yeah
you trying to solve puzzles we can play
together so we like play local code it's
really fun to play together I think that
I somebody else into yeah and know that
when you first start you're gonna be
like this game is dumb it is frustrating
I don't understand the controller but
then like
then the good kids yeah it gets ya in
the can the frustrating controls are
like part of why it's charm no funny
it's like part of why it's funny cuz
your booty wiggling oh yeah the booty
Wiggly there's not like yeah they wiggle
their booties off step in it's funny
yeah Evan made his character look like
Ron Swanson and I made my character look
like imagine peach but like with us
demonic snowman head yeah it's kind of
[Laughter]
we play on Twitch we've got a Miley
Cyrus this thing I think actually right
after this we're gonna build a robot
okay yeah we are which if you're
listening to this it's all right oh hey
thanks for joining us on another evident
p.m. podcast we really appreciate you
spending your time with us and we'll
look forward to making next one change
and make sure that you subscribe to the
Evan and Kaitlyn podcast YouTube channel
and give us a ring Oh since I made my
chair taller everything is weird now
that now you're like at your level
[Laughter]
that's how you got taller no no this is
always here okay shall we start okay